[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
everyone's wanting to know
how long are we banned from YouTube
well they banned us for seven days so we
got most of the week this week where
we're not on YouTube
that's right we're not on YouTube
it is a situation where we're not on
YouTube
but you can uh you can go watch you can
go watch live on Twitch Facebook Twitter
you can also watch on at tonymichaels
dot live I believe we're live over there
I don't know if it's um I don't know if
it's working yet or not it's a brand new
website we just set it up Tony Michaels
dot live and we set it up because of the
YouTube band
um that's just we had to go to
um the situation where we would have
uh
a place where you could go
and you could actually watch us
regardless of a YouTube band
uh so if you're over there watching uh
again I think it's I think it's
broadcasting live on Tony Michaels dot
live
and while you're over there you can
support Independent Media
because that's the thing if I can't get
this message out on YouTube or several
other places well you're not going to
get this message anyplace else so the
best way to support us there's a little
there's a little box right there next to
the feed
on Tony Michaels dot live
and you can donate you can do a one-time
tip or you can do a monthly tip where
you guys support us just one time or you
can support us
anytime you would like
um or you can do a monthly tip where you
set it to be a monthly amount and you
can choose the amount or you can use one
of the actual amounts but go over to
Tony Michaels dot live check out our
brand new website now we built it over
the weekend
to make sure that we could come live to
you this week
even though we're banned from YouTube
now here's what I want you to do
because even if we're banned
from YouTube okay it's okay I still want
you to go over there and follow us and
subscribe to our YouTube channel because
I want you to show YouTube
just tell me how much this ban means to
you is that you will support the Tony
Michaels podcast you will support
Independent Media you will support
pro-democracy speech even if they ban us
I want to tell you and a lot of folks
ask why why were they Banning us well
there was a video from about a year ago
you guys remember when a bunch of these
Q Anon nuts you know the ones that went
and hailed Trump this weekend they gave
the Nazi sign can you believe this [ __ ]
and a Nazi rally I've been calling them
Nazi rallies for a long time and be like
oh
you shouldn't say that and here they are
giving the Hitler salute uh oh
Tony Michaels was right doubt me
doubt me I mean just doubt me just
beginning to doubt me go to
store.dtonymichaels.com and get your
doubt me merch stickers t-shirts hoodies
coffee mugs because you definitely do
not want to doubt me you don't want to
doubt me on this
but here's the thing
here's the thing is that
we have to
stay vigilant
for the next 60 days and they banned us
because of the Q Anon nuts going to
school board meetings you remember this
I yelled and screamed about this for
months and months and months
about how ridiculous these people were
and how delusional they were to go to
school board meetings
and spew out misinformation lies into
continuing on and on on they go to
podiums why they would let them even
speak at these meetings I have no idea
no idea why they'd even let them speak
at these meetings
but they would because these are private
you know these are official government
meetings these are elected officials in
most cases for school board they do not
have to let someone speak in their
official proceeding your freedom of
speech stops at the door at official
proceeding you do not get to march on to
the Congressional floor the United
States has Representatives
and take over the house floor you will
get arrested you will go to prison
we've seen that
it's Criminal
to obstruct an official proceeding got
it
there you go
ow
I was talking about in the video that
they banned
these Q Anon nuts and the misinformation
that they were spreading I was mocking
them as I do
I was mocking them their delusional
beliefs
their Q Anon attitude because baby it's
a q Anon World we're just living in it
that YouTube I don't know I think
someone probably reported it there's a
lot of troll Farms out there right now
and the up in the uh lead up to the
election here I think they're trying to
silence several media and independent
voices they even banned Walter Masterson
I don't know if they banned his YouTube
channel too so must have been some troll
Farm attacking our channels but they got
they got that video taken down I
appealed as you would normally do I
appealed and YouTube said [ __ ] off now
I've contacted him several times to get
them to reconsider and they still told
me to [ __ ] off but that's okay that's
okay that's why we're here live on
Twitch
we're also live here on the new website
tonymichaels.live
Tony Michaels dot live so go over to
Tony Michaels dot live you can watch us
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on Tony Michaels dot live you can catch
us on a simulcast from Facebook
twitch and Twitter and soon soon by the
end of the week we'll be back on YouTube
I believe we will have YouTube back for
Friday and Friday's a great day to have
YouTube back because we have bonehead of
the week so we will have uh YouTube back
I'm not pissed off at YouTube uh you
know I'm mad at the troll Farms
and you know I I want them to reconsider
and I'm going to message them every day
this week get them to reconsider to try
to get back on YouTube because I feel
like the more we
talk to each other the more we encourage
each other the better off we are in this
situation because we've watched over the
weekend not only are the Republicans
human traffickers and boy they're really
leaning into it they're like oh you're
gonna call us human traffickers we're
gonna traffic More Humans okay
so we're going to talk about that today
because I have not had a chance to talk
about that because on Friday we had
Dakota and we had bonehead of the week
so I haven't had a chance to discuss the
human trafficking issue with you guys
and I'm gonna go over that and my
feelings about it
but we're also going to talk about this
Nazi rally this weekend and I've been
calling these Trump rallies Nazi rallies
for more than a year
more than a year I've been calling them
Nazi rallies
and here we are
where they're giving the Hitler's salute
to Donald Trump as he does some weird
despot thing it's really [ __ ] weird
they had the music going and he was
given some kind of [ __ ] Church q and
on religious speech or something I don't
know what the [ __ ] was going on it's
really [ __ ] weird
it's a cult folks it's a [ __ ]
cult for show
no way it's not a cult right am I wrong
is there something I'm missing here
because I I mean it's it's very strange
very strange
that these people would be talking about
you know this where we go one where we
go we talked about this a couple weeks
ago
with Jim stewartson and maybe I should
have Jim back on this week or next week
to talk about this [ __ ]
because you notice they weren't sticking
all their fingers out in the air when
they were hailing Trump
and you just had one finger because I
guess that's the where we go one we go
all the the Q Anon [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] religion just like Nazism
was a religion
look when we say there are so many
[ __ ] bullet points that you should be
worried about when you compare what is
happening now to what happened in 1930s
and 1940s Nazi Germany we are I'm not
[ __ ] around
the the the best part about our
situation here in this country is we
actually have a foundation of a
democracy they did not
they did not now they're trying to steal
it away from us folks they're trying to
take our democracy away from us Jesus
Christ Doug mastriano the Pennsylvania
Mussolini also was hailing Trump or some
[ __ ] giving some kind of hail Hitlers I
don't know it's [ __ ] weird it's weird
[ __ ]
and I said that they're obedient
fascist sheep because that's what they
are they're obedient fascist sheep
they're gonna believe anything these
[ __ ] morons tell them anything
absolutely anything they're even gonna
they're even gonna cheer
when Republican human traffickers spend
millions and millions of dollars to put
a a few dozen migrants on planes and
ship them halfway across the country and
leave them out in the middle of nowhere
spending millions and millions of
dollars in taxpayers money these are
people who used to [ __ ] about the
federal deficit
they used to complain about federal
spending and they're using Federal money
to not to not try to solve the problem
to make it worse
and possibly commit crime
I mean it seems like if you were a
governor and you were going to use
taxpayer money who that is designated
to help refugees in your state
in your state you wouldn't order a plane
in a state halfway across the country
get people in that plane fly them to
your state for a photo op using federal
government funds by the way
getting them off the plane doing a photo
op getting them back on gets sending
sending them to Martha's Vineyard
where they actually took care of those
people they treated them like human
beings not like [ __ ] meat
just just like we knew they would
the people in Martha's Vineyard weren't
going to turn these people away they're
gonna help these people clothe them feed
them shelter them try to get them back
where they need to be
because they need to be where their
hearings are at
for their Federal hearings because
they're refugees
they're trying to seek Asylum and they
have Asylum hearings in the courts
so those people in Martha's Vineyard did
their damnedest to help undo the 12
million dollar PR stunt
that Ron DeSantis did can you imagine
you're talking 240 000 per Refugee
there's 50 of them he spent 12 million
bucks 240
000 per refugee
think about that
think about it they're always talking
about how liberals waste money and
they're always into spending and wasting
spending get the [ __ ] out of here with
that nonsense
they're approving time and time again
they are all full on 100 projection
projection the entire lot of them
all of it is projection all of it
it's absolutely mind-boggling
that there are still people that are
still participating in this Maga Q Anon
Nazi America First fascism
that they don't see right through this
that this is all a bunch of [ __ ]
these people came here as [ __ ]
refugees to seek Asylum you [ __ ]
boneheads
and yes it is racist and Despicable to
load brown people on a plane in Texas
to exploit them
on a rich Island like Martha's Vineyard
because here's what they thought would
happen they really truly believed Ron
DeSantis that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] he
can go [ __ ] himself by the way
I don't know if you guys notice this
meme we made Rhonda santis can go [ __ ]
himself you can get it as a t-shirt
that's stored after Tony michaels.com
everyone really liked this design Ron
DeSantis can definitely 100 go [ __ ]
himself
Miranda santis his sentiment here was
his sentiment I'll let him Reach people
them Rich Elite liberals take care see
how you like it you rich Elite liberals
in Martha's Vineyard
what they thought was is they would drop
them off on the sidewalk
and the people in Martha's Vineyard
would cast these people aside and call
the police and have them arrested you
are dumb [ __ ] you are a dumb
[ __ ] Ron DeSantis you way Miss
calculated just like you're trying to
[ __ ] distract us from Roe look I
don't know about you but when you
[ __ ] take away people's human rights
in this country like they did with Roe
and then you treat brown people who are
trying to seek Asylum refugees
like [ __ ] pieces of meat
and you're dehumanizing them we see you
Rhonda santis we [ __ ] see you
what would Jesus do Ron what would Jesus
do these people aren't [ __ ]
Christians that's why they call
themselves Christian nationalists
because they're not [ __ ] Christians
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me you're saying
you're saying that the church would tell
refugees
Asylum Seekers
in this country
to come here
not only to tell them to [ __ ] off but to
lie to them put them in a cargo plane
and ship them to Martha's Vineyard and
drop them off on a sidewalk after
promising them jobs
and shelter in Massachusetts
well guess what those people in Martha's
Vineyard did they would do what any real
decent American would [ __ ] do in that
situation
they treated them like [ __ ] humans
they did what Jesus would do frankly
they did what Jesus would do your little
book that you people run around talking
about
they would do what Jesus would do that's
right because you know what those
[ __ ] refugees and their children and
their and their future grandchildren in
this country they are our future leaders
just like the immigrants and migrants
before them
their children their grandchildren who
were and are our leaders today
you don't think you don't think these
people are going to get Asylum here are
going to seek citizenship and get it
because they received what was the best
of America
after getting lied to by a fascist like
Ron DeSantis
those are the Future Leaders of our
country folks that's it just like the
migrants and immigrants before them
how do you [ __ ] think we got here
Ronda Santos you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you goddamn dirt bag
and anyone anyone who votes for that
piece of [ __ ] or anyone like him [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] bigot and we need to
call them out on the rug and we need to
keep calling them out you [ __ ]
bigots
how do you think this country was made
do you think do you think that all the
people here was just [ __ ] here no they
came here for a better life
just like those folks that Rhonda Santos
paid 240 000 per person to round up lied
to courts to get on a plane and sent
them to Martha's Vineyard where they
were taken care of not just by the
people of Martha's Vineyard but by the
Republican governor of Massachusetts
to try to get them back to where they
needed to be in time for their hearings
today
which they have the right to that
hearing dumb [ __ ]
it's the law they're refugees they're
seeking Asylum
they're not here illegally you dumb
[ __ ]
and even if they are
even if they are
that statue
it says
you're tired and you're poor because we
don't give a [ __ ] frankly frankly
I will take anyone anyone who's eager
to participate and to be part of our
democracy over these [ __ ] Q Anon
fascists who were sending Nazis hand
signals and salutes to Donald Trump and
the Pennsylvania Mussolini Doug
mastriano this weekend [ __ ] those
[ __ ] I'll trade you any day of
the week you son of a [ __ ]
and if you don't think if you don't
think this is a precursor
to what these people want to do round up
people in their states and send them out
to other places Jesus Christ Stephen
Miller was on Fox News talking about
putting them in the camps
he called them tit cities [ __ ] camps
that's what they want folks
fascism is knocking at the door Jesus
Christ they're they're even giving the
Nazi salute
at the Trump Nazi rally
listen to them when they're telling you
who they are [ __ ] listen
and you gotta do something about it
you have to engage in your democracy you
must
your family your friends your co-workers
your fellow parishioners at your church
the people at the PTA
the goddamn people in the Walmart
checkout line I'm telling you
they're not gonna know this stuff
they're not going to know the Despicable
[ __ ] that these people are up to until
it's too late
it's up to you it's up to us
people who are paying attention
who are pro-democracy because folks
that's that's the rub here
people are pro-democracy
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] five percent
of people
who think five percent
there's a poll which I don't believe
polls
farther than you can throw them
but there's a pull out that five percent
of Americans five percent
will do anything to get Trump back in
power even commit violence against what
the United States government you people
are a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
five percent of the country
is going to take over the rest of the
95. they're going to take away your way
of life well they will with government
they won't with violence they will with
government though you goddamn right they
will with government that's their
[ __ ] plan folks
that's their plan is to infiltrate your
government your democracy they're not
going to Riot in the streets they're not
going to commit violence and take over
our country five percent versus ninety
five percent get the [ __ ] out of here
but we know minority rule is a thing in
our democracy it is something we have to
fix and the only way to fix it is to
keep engaged
to keep engaged and what you can do is
to keep engaged you can do several
different things
a lot of different things stay on social
media spread around those pro-democracy
messages support pro-democracy
Independent Media like here at the Tony
Michaels podcast you go to Tony Michaels
dot live
and you could donate you can donate to
other
pro-democracy Independent Media Outlets
you could donate to candidates but the
most important thing
other than marking your ballot because
you have to you have to mark your ballot
for pro-democracy candidates you must
engage with your neighbors in your
community and your friends about these
issues
Jesus Christ we are Brett Favre down in
Mississippi stealing Federal money
to build a goddamn volleyball stadium
for his daughter at a university
all the while Jackson Mississippi can't
even [ __ ] drink their water
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
you don't think the P you don't people
in Mississippi should be ready to vote
against any [ __ ] that had
anything to do with any of this nonsense
and let me tell you they're all [ __ ]
Republicans every [ __ ] last one of
them every [ __ ] last one of them
don't let them fool you
they're the vial of the vile
the shittiest of the shittiest
and it's knocking on our front door
because I'm gonna show you the pictures
the video today because we don't look
away here at the Tony Michaels podcast
we don't look away I want to show you
what's going on
so do me a huge favor
do me a huge favor if you're on Facebook
go over to my Facebook page the Tony
Michaels
and follow me there go over to Twitch
follow us there follow me on Twitter
but go to Tony Michaels dot live and if
you can support independent Independent
Media there bookmark that page that's
where we will go live no matter what
no matter what and and also if you can
if you can if you can give there's a
little box on the side
where you can give a one-time tip or a
monthly tip
if you would like
one dollar five dollars whatever
whatever you can afford it all helps
keep us going and keep me yelling into
this microphone because I don't care if
YouTube bans me I don't give a [ __ ] I
wasn't that upset
the thing I was most upset about is that
you guys wouldn't get to hear what was
going on
because that's what I try to do every
single weekday Monday through Friday for
two full hours
is telling you guys how to engage give
you the ammo that you need I know it's
cathartic my yelling my anger
sometimes the humor
and I appreciate every single one of you
listening
sticking through the YouTube band
and coming here every single day so
don't forget to go over to YouTube and
show them what we're worth and subscribe
to our Channel over there if you're not
already
and also go over to Twitter and follow
us at Tony Michaels pod you're not going
to want to miss a tweet
as we update you on the ban as it's
lifted and go download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify Julie your
favorite directory do not forget to
download every single episode and while
you're subscribing on that directory for
the Tony Michaels podcast make sure
you're leaving us a great review also
follow us on Twitch
don't forget to follow us over there on
Twitch
and again you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
or go to
tonymichaels.live Tony Michaels dot live
all the socials are at the very top
and you can click the little sandwich
icon and you'll get the follow links
where you can go follow us everywhere
Tony Michaels dot live Tony Michaels dot
live
boy I really appreciate uh the audience
here you guys that we couldn't do this
without you without the support that you
give
without your encouragement without all
the comments uh hell I I even like the
trolls giving comments that's right
there's trolls here every single day
they come back every single day and
we'll turn them one of these days
but I love every single one of you and I
love that you're here listening because
I love I love giving you this cathartic
messaging that you can use to go out and
engage in your democracy
it is something that I hope I can
continue to do for a very very long time
I do not want to quit matter of fact I
want to go to three hours I think you
guys need three hours
because there's a lot of [ __ ]
oh boy there's a lot of stuff I mean we
got two Nazi rallies where they're
giving the Hitler salute this weekend
two of them
in one weekend that we gotta cover
so please support Independent Media go
to Tony Michaels dot live you can watch
us live there every single day you can
also donate and you can find some other
cool stuff we're gonna we're gonna keep
editing that website we're gonna keep
editing it uh we've got some YouTube
playlists there that you can go back and
watch some old episodes
um and we'll have more stuff there we're
gonna we're we just opened a Discord uh
which I think that's gonna be a great
place for us to all go to and
communicate with each other and talk to
each other I want like-minded
pro-democracy people inside of a
community talking to each other engaging
with each other giving each other ideas
not just spreading around memes I mean
that's cool that's fun I like that but
giving each other ideas
sending each other where to follow where
to go who to support what these
candidates are
because folks we are so close to the
2022 midterm so close
but as soon as it's over because this is
the most important election of our
democracy's lifetime
this one right here in front of us
and as soon as it's over as soon as
those votes are counted and certified
and we know that we'll have a Blue Wave
because it's you it's you out there
doing this
the next election will be the most
important of our democracy's lifetime
and we will have to keep engaging I will
not quit I mean as soon as it's called
as soon as the Democrats take the Senate
they hold the house they take Governor's
Races they take legislators around the
country because it's going to be you who
engages and pushes them over the line
as soon as we get there I'm not going to
stop yelling nope [ __ ] no hell to the no
I'm gonna keep going so follow
tonymichaels.live go bookmark right now
Tony Michaels dot Live support
Independent Media there everyone stick
around we'll be right back with the
shitless Roundup right after these
messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
don't forget
Tony Michaels dot live
support Independent Media there you can
watch the show live we're broadcasting
live
from our brand new website folks brand
new website we are we are live on Tony
Michaels dot live you can watch us there
every single weekday you can also follow
us on Facebook
you can follow us on Twitch Twitter and
YouTube don't forget just go to
tonymichaels.live at the very top
there's a little sandwich icon it says
follow Tony just click those and you can
find the links everywhere on Tony
michaels.live we're going to be really
updating that website as we go along
here we put that together over the
weekend now for you guys to have a spot
where you can watch us even if we
couldn't get the YouTube man lifted now
we appreciate you guys everyone sticking
around and hanging out
and listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast even though we've had a little
situation with YouTube we've had a
little situation with the YouTube you
know it goes that way it goes that way
so go right now to Tony michaels.y
bookmark that page you're going to want
to bookmark the page so that way you
never miss a single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast
and you can watch live every single day
and you can download the episodes of
course that's what I want you to do is
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify Google your favorite directory
forget to go there also you can follow
us on Twitch I don't know if you guys
think twitch is sort of like YouTube
it's kind of like YouTube your best bet
is to download the app I know it's
another app but
you can watch all kinds of bro democracy
channels over there there's all kinds of
folks
that stream on Twitch for pro-democracy
speech
so follow us on Twitch just type in the
Tony Michaels you'll find us there or
again you can go to Tony Michaels
not live and you can follow us in the
twitch icon is right at the top of the
page and while you're there support
Independent Media give us a tip either
one time or each month you can set to
give us a tip there are Tony Michaels
dot live it's at the very top it looks
just like this here just like this
little box here kind of gave you a
little example of that this morning
holy moly we got a lot of video to get
to look
Gabe Sanchez is still still in his deep
State underground bunker and
I don't know where it is this time he's
not going to be joining us today we were
hoping he was going to be able to join
us today but he's he's still in travel
mode so Gabe will not join us today you
had you just got me today you just got
me but tomorrow Gabe Sanchez will join
us
uh during the Tony Michaels podcast at
this time of the hour because we love
the [ __ ] list here I know you love to
round up the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends so let's do this let's go surfing
[ __ ] start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
of all the Tweety tweets and the trendy
trends of the day
oh boy there's a lot of stuff to round
up we gotta have a a storm in Puerto
Rico that shut off a bunch of power
again and the queen is still having her
funeral are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
Jesus Christ will you bury her already
[ __ ] we listen all the networks this
morning that's all they were talking
about we have people holding Nazi
rallies that are trying to take office
and take control of our democracy
they're holding Nazi rallies and these
dumb [ __ ] in the media are
paying attention to the Queen's funeral
what the [ __ ] are you doing you have you
have actual fascists who are taking the
rights away from women who are human
trafficking refugees and Asylum Seekers
all across the country it's paying
hundreds hundreds of thousands of
dollars per person to traffic these
people to own the libs it really doesn't
make any sense and the media what are
they doing what the [ __ ] are they doing
oh the Queen's gonna get buried the
queen has been being buried for last two
[ __ ] months it seems like shut the
[ __ ] up who gives a [ __ ] if you care
about that go go over there [ __ ] we do
not want to hear more about the [ __ ]
Queen I just don't want to hear it
anymore I don't want to hear it we got
enough of our own [ __ ] problems
here I'm sorry I'm sorry respect to the
queen but [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm we got we
got people Gathering up at Nazi rallies
ready to take violence to the streets to
overthrow our governments to get inside
of our governments like the Pennsylvania
governorship with Pennsylvania's
Mussolini Doug mastriano I'm not
[ __ ] you
I'm not [ __ ] you these obedient
sheep are like that
John Voight is trending probably because
of some [ __ ] dumb video we'll
definitely watch that there's a there's
a video from somewhere down south in a
bar where a bunch of racists are talking
to
a black woman
um let's see what else do we have
there's a Ken Burns film out about World
War II hmm
wonder if that uh will tell you anything
probably show you a lot of [ __ ] that's
going on right now as we speak
um there's apparently a 60 Minutes
interview with the president uh Glenn
yunken is doing some nasty [ __ ] in
Virginia
oh who would have guessed that you elect
a republican to be a governor and
they're going to do some dumb [ __ ] I
wonder how that worked out
uh Antichrist is also trending so is
rapey mcforhand how appropriate
um rapey mcforhead is trending as the
governors of the state are of our United
States are trafficking humans illegally
trafficking humans very interesting
but again the main story that I want to
focus on is these Nazis they're Q Anon
Nazis
don't believe me just watch the [ __ ]
tape
and I don't know what else did I don't
know what else to do I don't know how
else to prove it to you
here is uh here is uh let's uh change
this up there we go
here's the profile let's go to Twitter
I'm telling you
I'm telling you
this is um here is the video from
the Nazi rally in Pennsylvania
uh Tristan has it here he says yes this
is a Nazi salute and a Doug mastriano
campaign event in Pennsylvania in 2022
democracy is literally on the ballot in
November
okay now this is a this is a campaign
event for the Pennsylvania Mussolini
Doug mastriano here see if I can get the
volume yeah there we go again I think I
got it now listen to this you can see
here it's mastriano for governor
now listen to what happens in this video
it's only 33 seconds
listen to the obedient fascist sheep
here
and we'll do that by putting our right
hand at the air on the count of three
willing to do that
oh my God he even he they even know they
even are aware of the symbolism here
they are even oh wait look at these
[ __ ] sheep these [ __ ] Nazi sheep
they're deluded they're brainwashed they
are mind [ __ ] here
into this Q Anon fascism [ __ ]
he even says if you're willing to do it
holy actual [ __ ]
if you're willing to do the Nazi salute
you know be my guest
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me nope not
[ __ ] you you're my favorite turd
wouldn't [ __ ] you watch this [ __ ]
can you say what they said at Gettysburg
look at these people look at these
[ __ ] people
you see the old guy right here
this guy's probably old enough to
remember
stories
about 1930s and 1940s Germany right
and then right behind him is a younger
lady younger woman here in the Hat her
arm is straight the [ __ ] out his arm not
so much he's like man this is kind of
gross her hell no she's full-on Nazi
let's do this I'm gonna pledge my
allegiance let's listen
father I pray that indeed Pennsylvania
will be like little round time and
America will have a new birth
and this morning
whoosh
whoosh if that's not if if that's I I
just I I don't know how to [ __ ] even
are you not paying attention are you not
paying attention I've been [ __ ]
yelling and screaming it for months and
months and months Nazi rally Nazi rally
Nazi rally Nazi rally
oh Tony you're being ridiculous oh I am
huh
doubt me
speaking of doubt me doubt me merch
everyone wants it
it's flying off the shelves
just doubt me just [ __ ] doubt me I'm
telling you when I say something here
I'm not just saying it to be fancy I'm
[ __ ] being dead serious these people
are coming for your [ __ ]
they're coming for it and I don't just
mean your government I mean your [ __ ]
Church your goddamn School your house
your [ __ ] property
they're gonna come for your [ __ ]
you don't think you don't think if you
live in a red or a blue or a purple
state
that they won't put you on a plane and
spend whatever money they have to to
ship you somewhere else you don't think
they'll do that
you don't think they'll ship you off to
a tent city as Stephen Miller said
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] we're gonna watch
that video
you talk about [ __ ] full-on Nazi
here is the um
uh here's the contrast with the Trump
Nazi rally because Doug mastriano had
his own the the Pennsylvania Mussolini
had his own uh Nazi rally now our our
co-host Gabe Sanchez says we're not our
fire shifts here's the picture from the
Trump rally
got it see how they had the one finger
up that's a [ __ ] Q Anon thing
here's the Nazis in Germany
look familiar over the weekend
look familiar oh my God
oh my God they're here and they're mine
[ __ ] and they're brain dead
it's happening folks I told you it would
just [ __ ] doubt me on this
now
here is the actual video because this
[ __ ] is wild
the [ __ ] is [ __ ] Wild
if you haven't seen this
you're about to
get a gut punch because the picture is
one thing
in the video without sound is another
this is [ __ ] wild [ __ ] I said it's
almost like Jim Jones Hitler and Bozo
the Clown [ __ ] and had a baby
it's it's some wild ass [ __ ]
while that [ __ ] I don't know if you guys
have ever watched a documentary on
Jonestown
but these people God damn if they were
if they were [ __ ] passing out
Kool-Aid at this goddamn rally
every single one of these dumb
[ __ ] be dead
every one of them
David drank the [ __ ] Kool-Aid even
the people in the background here
and it's the same [ __ ] folks
it's the same people
there's not that many new people going
to these [ __ ] rallies listen you're
talking about five percent of the
country
five
five percent of the country
will follow this [ __ ] [ __ ]
into the abyss here if he's indicted or
if they lose the midterms or whatever
the [ __ ] whatever but whatever new goal
post that they have that they move
because that's all this is it's just a
the moving of the goal post
but this video
holy [ __ ]
telling you
you're gonna wanna watch this and not
only and it's got five million views
just on Aaron's post this is Aaron
rupar's uh post from Newsmax on his
Twitter account and this this video here
just this video has five million views
it should have 500 million views folks
you have to show this to your [ __ ]
family you gotta show it to your friends
you gotta show it to them and you gotta
tell them what the [ __ ] it is because
this isn't just him talking with some
weird-ass music with them giving a Nazi
salute that's not what this is
this is mind [ __ ] this is
brainwashing active brainwashing
watch this [ __ ]
we are a nation that allowed Russia to
devastate a country Ukraine
killing oh Jesus Christ
okay do you hear the music in the
background
so before we get started here the music
in the background is q a and then I'm
not going to play a ton of this but you
have to watch the whole two minutes
you gotta watch it and you gotta show it
to people that you know that you care
about
these [ __ ] are gonna come for
them
I'm telling you
watch hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse it would
never have happened with me as your
commander-in-chief
and for four long years it didn't happen
again if you've watched any kind of
documentary on Jim Jones and Jonestown
you would know that he used to get on
the microphone in Jonestown he had like
a like an overhead speaker and he would
give these long-ranting speeches he
would call everyone into the Pavilion
and give these long-ranting speeches
about oh whoa the government's after him
they're coming to get him oh my God and
if they come to get him they're going to
come to get you two and all this
nonsense
I don't know if you ever listened to Jim
those Jim Jones recordings but they are
off the chain
this is way worse way worse
Jim Jones
had to go all the way to Jonestown to do
that nonsense
they're doing it right here in
Youngstown Ohio folks
these people have lost their minds the
way they're way way way way way
off the tracks here
they lost their way they're mine [ __ ]
by this piece of [ __ ] and everyone gave
me [ __ ] about this tweet because I
called him I said I said uh Jim Jones
Hitler and Boza the clown [ __ ] and had
a baby be like ah you're insulting Bozo
I was calling him a clown you fox I'm
just picking out the most famous Clan
there is Bozo the Clown I'm not saying
Bozo's bad just saying Bozo's a clown
he's a clown act this guy's a [ __ ]
clown Act
but the music in this video is Q Anon
this is the Q Anon music they play when
they do their oath
to their to their Trump religion Q Anon
folks this guy wants to be Hitler
I'm not [ __ ] you this [ __ ]
wants to be Hitler
and he sees an opening and an
opportunity and he's gonna try to take
it
because these people are [ __ ] dumb
they're dumber than a bag of hammers
and he's gonna exploit them
and he's doing it right here in this
video by playing this music having them
giving the Q Anon one signal the Nazi
salute
as he Rambles on about his Grievances
and how they must protect him listen to
this
and China with Taiwan is next oh my God
we are a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party
like never ever before like like the
last the last president did like now we
know the last president did
he weaponized the justice department to
protect himself and against his
political allies
it's all projection all of it
every single bit of it just like Jim
Jones just like Hitler maybe not like
Bowser the Clown
but you know riding around on a tricycle
with a red nose and a [ __ ] clown wig
here
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election changing facts to be presented
to the public what
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
the Federal Bureau of Investigation is
not letting election facts being shown
do the but what are you talking you
talking about the you mean how Mike
Lindell and Tina Peters and you and your
allies tried to steal the election by
tampering with voting machines you mean
that you mean that kind of information
oh we're gonna find that out Grandpa
Poopypants soon enough
where Hunter Biden's laptop oh God okay
I can't I can't I can't do it I can't do
it uh up until honor Biden's laptop
thing I was cool but I can't I can't do
that under buying laptop but you gotta
go watch this I'm gonna retweet it right
now to the top of the feed you have to
go watch this video and you gotta show
people
who you know and who you love
you got to show them this [ __ ] video
you have
to do it
it is the only thing that may save our
country
it's the only thing
because these are the people that he's
deluding this one right here
this lady is one of his Avid supporters
they have his father she's a queuing on
her
and this is Christina Bob here
interviewing her on rsbn
hmm they must be all out of [ __ ]
Talent
all right right I mean Christina Bob
she's got to be his attorney and she's
got to be the rsbn host that [ __ ]
interviews these people and Halloween
costumes and I'm not exaggerating I'm
not lying I'm telling the truth it's a
[ __ ] Halloween costume listen to this
[ __ ] and I served the airports for 21
years I'm a January 6th defendant can we
say that
okay first off she's a veteran she took
the oath of office
and she broke her oath
by storming the capital and trying to
overthrow our government because the
Cheeto dust mobster convinced her of
that
but listen to what she says about her
her outfit I'm not you know I don't give
a [ __ ] what anyone wears I really don't
give a [ __ ] honestly a people dressed up
like this around Joe Biden and Democrats
we might get we might get somewhere with
this pro-democracy stuff I'm not saying
we shouldn't have our own circus
hell I would be more than happy to help
facilitate a circus
hell I am part of the circus for that
matter
and listen to what she says about this
get up and more importantly about how
many times
how many times she's put this outfit on
and I wrote a poem called we're ready
I'll be our gift to you that sounds
great you look fantastic what prompted
the outfit
I started that okay this is Christina
Bob this is the attorney that is
supposed to be helping Trump
make sure that he makes his case that he
did not steal classified information
and obstruct Justice and she's asking
the really tough question she's doing
the really hard work
at the Trump rally asking this lady
how'd you get this outfit how'd you get
this thing going holy [ __ ] it's after
the election was stolen I actually had
bought it as a Halloween costume and I
was in Arizona doing a patriot party out
there and my costume was in Abilene
Texas so I was like I need to find a
reason to wear it so the first time I
wore it was November of 2021 and I'm
back at car rally and then it just
became a thing and I wear it to all the
events now I wear it to all the events
did you catch that
she goes to Arizona to Abilene Texas and
now she's in young towns Ohio folks
these people are traveling around the
country eggs groupies
I'm not I don't I don't want to
disparage The Grateful Dead here but
this is almost like
the deadheads right
these people are traveling around the
country no matter where he goes
so you can better well bet and I almost
I I almost bet we're gonna find this out
in court eventually doubt me telling you
doubt me go get your merch
because you're gonna need it here's the
thing
the Trump the Trump save America Pact
is paying money to have these people
travel around the country and attend
these events no question
are you kidding me you think Rhonda
Santos is the only one playing for plane
trips all around the country hell to the
no
they're paying these people's travel
expenses I bet Bottom Dollar
they're paying these people's travel
expenses to come here they come to these
events and to pack these [ __ ]
stadiums they would be half as full
these Nazi rallies you're talking about
five percent of the country I'm gonna
show you the [ __ ] tape from Face the
Nation of the pole I'm gonna show it to
you here
we do not look away here at the Tony
Michaels podcast
this lady's been to all the events all
the all the events with this Halloween
costume Jesus [ __ ] Christ
Oh Lordy okay well let's let's move on
to um
uh some more craziness I'm telling you
these people want to take your country
away from you
they're ready
they're ready to take your country away
from you here is um here's another clip
from this Nazi really this is the other
thing uh he keeps he keeps talking about
drug dealers
uh here's Grandpa poopy pants on drug
dealers
and I'm calling for the death penalty
for drug dealers and human traffickers
wait wait wait wait wait I caught drug
dealers but did you hear what else he
said because it's kind of funny about
the drug dealers because he pardoned a
bunch of drug dealers and his son
his son wouldn't be able to make
internet videos without his drug dealer
to be quite honest
but did you hear did you hear the second
thing he wants to give the death penalty
to drug dealers and who else tell us
again
and I'm calling for the death penalty
yeah drug dealers and human traffickers
human traffickers you know well this
makes sense this really does make sense
that Trump would want to give the death
penalty to human traffickers I mean he
really wants to make sure that Rhonda
Santos is not
is not his political rival during the
2024 presidential campaign so that makes
sense that he'd want to give Ron
DeSantis the bet that penalty honestly
Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself
Rhonda santis can go [ __ ] himself to be
honest with you that [ __ ] human
trafficker uh go get your rock the
scientists can go [ __ ] him up merch and
store that the Tony michaels.com it's a
brand new design
a brand new Ronda Santos can go [ __ ]
himself designed
listen this is getting a little out of
hand but I want to give you some hope
here
I want to give you some hope against
these fascists because there was this
video out of the University of New
Mexico where uh Tomi Lauren you know
tell me Lauren
the Barbie fascist you know what I'm
talking about on Fox News and Blaze TV I
got nowhere
she was supposed to speak at the
University of Mexico and students showed
up and this is what happened
wow
so they're so they're shouting outside
the auditorium where Tommy Lauren is
gonna speak and they're sh they're
shouting
um
shut it down shut it down shut it down
shut it down now
there could be a lot of reasons why
these students are yelling shut it down
I mean maybe there's too many people
there maybe they're against fire code
but they make it very clear here in the
next little chant
[Music]
black lives matter
so when they say they're scared of
wokeism
what they actually mean
is they're scared of being exposed
that's what the [ __ ] they mean
because this is what we need more of
this is what we need more of
okay let's see what else oh we got some
more um
oh we have some Marjorie Taylor green
footage here oh Margaret tether green
another Nazi
let's just keep them coming
here's something interesting so Air
Canada get this has ordered 30 electric
airplanes
okay so Canada has ordered 30 like this
is interesting I don't know what what
the [ __ ] does this I don't I don't
understand I mean that's kind of cool
actually that sounds pretty cool
electric planes you mean we're not gonna
have to use fuel like fossil fuel to fly
around big commercial airliners sounds
interesting sounds kind of cool actually
but I don't think that's where she's
going with this you know she's she she's
totally against solar panels she doesn't
know how batteries work and she doesn't
know how electric motors work apparently
listen
yeah electric airplanes
oh [ __ ]
electric airplanes so I mean it
shouldn't surprise you look who's the
president of I mean Justin Trudeau right
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
electric airplanes
Justin Trudeau is the president so
somehow we're supposed to make an
association with with the president of
Canada and electric airplanes what the
[ __ ] are you talking about lady
what is this nonsense
oh you're dumb [ __ ] here let's let's
I'll oblige you
so we were we were joking around and we
were talking how is there an electric
airplane and what does that look like so
we were oh God damn how is there an
electric airplane and what does it look
like well number one dumb [ __ ] it
probably appears to be I don't know an
airplane
does she does she think airplanes have
wings and [ __ ] just for the look
does she not does she not know how
airlift works
holy [ __ ]
and this is the person that Georgia has
elected and she goes around talking
about [ __ ]
solar energy
and renewable energy as if she knows
anything about it talking about how
they're going to turn off her dishwasher
and her washing machine because they're
going to be on elect what are you
talking about
she doesn't know what an airplane she
doesn't know why an airplane looks like
an airplane holy [ __ ] we were just
making fun and thinking about remember
back a long time ago and you've seen
movies where people in those slave ships
a wild right turn here to uh slavery she
went directly from how do electric
airplanes look to slave ships and
slavery
oh you just knew this was gonna get into
bigger tree with this [ __ ] Nazi
and they're being whipped to row
hiring these electric airplanes what are
they gonna
oh my God she literally she does not
know
does she not know what [ __ ] batteries
are
does this [ __ ] bonehead not know what
[ __ ] batteries are are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
how are they gonna Power electric
airplane does she think you have to hook
it up to a court or some [ __ ] how does
she think her [ __ ] cell phone works
are you
I'm dead serious what in the [ __ ] is
with this she didn't know what batteries
are
come on Jesus and then with the battery
battery bigotry here is [ __ ] oh boy
it's a new it's a new low even for this
even for this [ __ ]
where where they've got everybody riding
Space
and then those mean nasty airline
stewardess that force you to wear masks
all the time on the planes back when we
were forced to wear masks so they're not
forcing you to wear a mask anymore
because the policies have changed
because Joe Biden did what he was
supposed to do and tried to get us past
the pandemic now you don't have to wear
a mask but they used to but those nasty
stewardess now that don't work humor Max
you used to because it was probably what
the [ __ ] is she talking about what is
she talking about spin Cycles
and she's saying that people on the
airplane are going to be riding bicycles
to power the light bulb type thing
you've seen this right where they have a
bicycle set up and you ride the bicycle
to power the light bulb
Jesus Christ
this is really this is really this is
the brain power they have folks this is
all they got they can't figure out how
renewable energy and batteries work [ __ ]
but they could be forcing you to like
keep spinning to keep the airplane in
the air
like it's absurd yeah it sure is absurd
you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ] what an
idiot this person is an actual elected
official of Congress
they thought it was a good idea to put
her in charge of [ __ ]
people in Georgia
listen it's not really it's not really a
problem that we have
so much so with these politicians
it really is the [ __ ] people
these people are mind [ __ ]
their minds are mush
he had too much queuing on going around
in it
oh in other news uh yeah you guys have
seen this true social [ __ ] right I guess
they're [ __ ] broke hmm
how the [ __ ] didn't you see this coming
true social is broken no one wants to
fund it apparently the SPAC has failed
to pay proxy firm despite
tough hunt for votes
so all these [ __ ] Trump humping
idiots out there
who are at these rallies throwing up
their little Q Anon
hail Hitler finger whatever the hell it
is
they're all gonna lose their asses
on true social because you know that you
know it's a bunch of [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] that dumped their entire
retirement into this idiot's fraud
social media
oh absolutely hundo percento
all right let's move on to the uh the
migrants
um and maybe we'll move back to the the
Nazi rallies here is a Ted Cruz
describing the um
the human trafficking that went on let's
listen and
for sending the immigrants to these blue
cities I commend Ron DeSantis for doing
so and they need to do more tomorrow
Martha's Vineyard needs a hundred the
next day they need 200 the next day they
need a thousand D.C says it's a crisis
to get six thousand they need ten
thousand they need a hundred thousand
they need 500 000 because okay so let me
get this straight
Ted Cruz is definitely endorsing human
trafficking here
and is that what I get from the
beginning he's definitely endorsing
human trafficking but then he wants them
to have hundreds of thousands so is he
encouraging more people to seek asylum
in the United States
is he encouraging more refugees to come
seek Asylum here because really honestly
I'm I'm all for that
I'm all for that I'm all for the Asylum
Seekers coming to our country the
refugees coming to our country and
seeking Asylum here and being an
integral part of our economy I'm with
Ted Cruz yeah let's have a half million
of them hell let's do three or four
million of them that's really probably
about the number that we need
of migrants to come here to this country
to help fill the labor Gap we still have
help wanted signs up all over the
country our economy is rolling along
wrong we have record low unemployment
the demand is is higher than ever
inflation is cooling now so which is
only going to drive the economy even
more
yeah we're gonna need we're gonna need
we're gonna need people to participate
in this economy you goddamn right
we're going to need people to train them
to do jobs we're going to train we need
to train them to work
we need to educate them
and we're going to need a whole new
generation of leaders in this country
so yeah I I mean honestly this is one of
the weirdest ways that Ted Cruz could
ever describe this thing
he endorses human trafficking and then
he wants a half a million Asylum Seekers
refugees to come here
to come to our country and participate
in our economy
and grow our economy
yeah I I mean I you know normally I tell
Ted Cruz to eat [ __ ] now he can eat [ __ ]
on the endorsing human trafficking
but you know what's funny about this
and I was thinking about this over the
weekend
you remember when Barack Obama was
president said last year Barack Obama
was President
and there were more and more people
pouring over the border to seek Asylum
here
from some of these countries like
Venezuela
and these refugees seeking Asylum here
they were processing them
and then they were sending them
throughout the country do you remember
then
do you remember them yelling and
screaming and bitching and moaning ow
you're sending all these people all over
the country
the difference was is that Barack Obama
and the administration at the time was
notifying
where they were going making sure they
had shelters making sure they had places
for these people to go
do you remember do you remember
in 2021 just last year
when Afghanistan
we were leaving at the the the worthless
war that we'd been in for 20 years in
Afghanistan As Trump as he left office
negotiated with terrorists negotiated
with the Taliban which is not surprising
now gave the country the Afghanistan
country back to the Taliban
and then DOD and the Biden
administration had to fulfill the order
to give Afghanistan back to the town man
you remember that
you remember when Joe Biden had all
those refugees not just go to Europe but
come here to this country remember what
they said about those people flying into
our parts of the country flying into
flying into the United States freaking
the [ __ ] out
now they're all for it Ted Cruz is all
for it here
Ted Cruz here is all for shipping these
people all over the country which I mean
I'm not against
I'm not against it
I actually think it's a good goddamn
idea now the only thing I'm against is
preventing these people that to go
to their goddamn Asylum seeking hearings
where they're seeking Asylum legally in
this country because that's the one
thing these pieces of [ __ ]
are doing is making it out like these
people are illegals they're not illegals
they're seeking Asylum there is a legal
path to seek Asylum here and that's what
a lot of these folks are doing
and they're gonna stay here because of
that because there's a legal Avenue in
this country to seek Asylum there always
has been and there always should be
really honestly we should
welcome these people to our country
these people want to be here they want
to work they want to be contributing
members of society
and if you don't believe me
if you don't believe me just you just
look
at the video that we watched
this weekend
in Martha's Vineyard
for these folks
they weren't they weren't turned away
they weren't treated in human
they were treated
like people
as if your neighbors
came to Martha's Vineyard
and lost their house lost their job
needed clothes needed food
and they delivered
Martha's Vineyard
delivered
here's a little excerpt from how they
responded
to Ronda Santos vile human trafficking
effort as a PR strong stunt to own the
libs costing the taxpayers of Florida
240 000 per person who went there listen
arrived last night make it clear that
they were lied to again and again
and fraudulently induced to board
Thrive last
oh maybe arrived last night make it
clear that they were lied to again and
again
and fraudulently induced to board the
plains they were told there was a
surprise present for them and that there
would be jobs and housing a waiting for
them when they arrived this was
obviously a sadistic lie
not only did those responsible for this
stunt know that there was no housing and
no employment awaiting the migrants they
also very intentionally chose not to
call ahead to any single office
Authority on Martha's Vineyard so that
even the most basic human needs
Arrangements could be made ensuring that
no help awaited the migrants at all was
the entire point
they were provided with a cartoonishly
simple map of Martha's Vineyard in the
United States and a brief brochure
containing Snippets from the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts website
and instructions to change their address
with USCIS when they relocated this is
especially troubling as anyone with even
the most basic understanding of the
immigration proceedings knows that USCIS
was not the agency with whom the
migrants would have to record their
addresses and has nothing to do with
their cases in any way
it is clear that this was an intentional
attempt to ensure that these migrants
were removed In Absentia when they
failed to change their address with the
proper agency this was a purposeful
derailment designed to prevent people
from complying with Federal immigration
policies this is problematic because the
state should not be interfering with
Federal immigration policy
before they boarded the planes the
migrants were processed by agents of the
Department of Homeland Security who
listed falsified addresses on the
migrants paperwork
agents apparently chose random homeless
shelters of all across the country from
Washington to Florida
to list the migrants mailing addresses
even when told by the migrants that they
had no address in the U.S
according to the paperwork provided to
them the migrants are required to check
in with ice office nearest to the fake
address chosen for them by DHS or be
permanently removed from the United
States
with some required to check in as early
as this coming Monday
thank you
it could not be clearer that this is an
attempt to ensure that these people are
ordered removed even as they try as hard
as they can to comply with the
instructions provided to them there is
no other reason to list if someone's
mailing address a homeless shelter in
Tacoma Washington when they ship him to
Massachusetts it is sickeningly cruel
throwing obstacles in the way of people
fleeing violence and oppression some of
whom walked through 10 countries in the
hopes of finding safe safety it is
shameful and inhuman many of these
victims were deprived of Medical Care
despite clear existing injuries these
are human beings who were deprived of
basic human rights
to the people who find themselves
these wonderful people who find
themselves plane wrecked on our Island
I have a message for all of them
You Are Not Alone
we have your backs we are proud to be
here for you
and we've got you
if the intention of those who
perpetrated this horrendous Act was to
create a crisis you have failed
their demeanor is kind their demeanor is
grateful and their demeanor is just that
they want to be doing everything right
their biggest concern today is that many
of them have dates to appear in San
Antonio Monday morning Tacoma Washington
Monday morning Washington D.C Monday
morning you tell me how that's possible
we will be exploring all civil and
criminal legal options to hold the
perpetrators accountable
Retro Retro up more more GOP manga
Republican crime hmm
uh-oh rat row
listen this is this is how America works
let me let me let me break it down for
you folks out there who don't understand
who are who are Maga Republicans out
there that the trolls that are listening
this is how America works
it's called human decency
right that's what we believe in in this
country
we have for a while we haven't always
believed that way we haven't always been
a decent group of people
and we can always get better
it's what we need to get better
when you have
refugees
people seeking Asylum to this country
brave people who tracked with their
families their children
come to our country
to be part of our economy
to be part of our great democracy
to participate
in the greatest country on Earth
regardless of if they thought they were
going to get some high paying job or low
paying job they didn't care
just to have a chance to come to this
country
and to be in our great democracy
The Shining City on the hill
and we are going to be bigoted and turn
them away
act like these people are pieces of meat
use them as props
and a 12 million dollar political stunt
designed to own the libs
how [ __ ] Christian of you Ron
DeSantis how [ __ ] Christian of you
Greg Abbott you pieces of [ __ ]
garbage and anyone I mean anyone out
there making excuses for this
I don't give a [ __ ] what the excuses
what the LIE is what the [ __ ] line
is fake Gabe I see you over there in the
comments you pop vile piece of trash
anyone making excuses for this is a
[ __ ] bigot and is Un-American and is
not a patriot doesn't understand how our
country was [ __ ] made what the people
here who lead our great nation who have
made it what it is today
by coming here seeking Refuge seeking
Asylum
and becoming part of the American dream
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't go telling me excuses about this
[ __ ] because the people in Martha's
Vineyard did exact opposite of what Greg
Abbott and Rhonda Santos and the rest of
these [ __ ] idiots wanted
the exact opposite they treated these
people like human [ __ ] beings they
never dreamed that they're like oh these
liberals won't treat them like human
beings it's all liberal [ __ ] talk
and they did they fed them they clothed
them they took them in they tried to
figure out a way to get them shelter
they try to figure out a way to get them
back to their goddamn hearings so they
don't get so they don't get taken out of
this country because they miss their
hearing of us to seek Asylum here these
are going to be citizens you [ __ ]
idiots these people who who Rhonda
santis put on planes to traffic them
across state lines as a PR stunt a 12
million dollar PR stunt to own the libs
are going to be citizens one day
listen to me when I tell you this
they're gonna be [ __ ] citizens
and their children and their
grandchildren are going to be Congress
people they're going to be Business
Leaders they're going to be lawyers
they're going to be doctors they're
going to be [ __ ] teachers they're
going to be the garbage men cleaning up
our streets every single week
they're going to be checking you out at
grocery stores making sure the shelves
are stocked they're gonna be trucking
Goods across the country in a semi truck
or on the Railroad Union
these are the future
of America
that's what these folks are
the future of America and and people out
there who are making excuses
for what these human traffickers these
criminal human traffickers like Greg
Abbott and Ron DeSantis have done
by tearing down and dismissing someone's
Humanity for a political stunt
people like you
buddy
you're a Dying Breed
your dying breed
it's not many left a piece of [ __ ] like
this watch this watch this [ __ ] watch
this vile piece of trash policies that
have led his border with Mexico to be
declared the deadliest border crossing
in the entire world what is inhumane are
his policies that attract people who
lose their lives who are being human
trafficked who are victims of rape and
even murder and so what the president
needs to understand is he is killing
people with his open border policies and
he's destroying his own country but not
enforcing the immigration law let me
show we don't have real immigration laws
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] we haven't
done immigration reform in this country
since Ronald Reagan
over 30 years it's been
since we Revisited our immigration
policies that's why people are dying at
the [ __ ] border that's why you can't
get a handle on people coming across the
border
that's why you can't distinguish the
difference you racist piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
if you would do your [ __ ] job
do you mind you know that's the craziest
part about this whole thing is just put
them in charge right just put them in
charge just put them in charge and
they'll fix it just put them in charge
and they'll fix it as if as if When
Donald Trump was in charge no one was
coming across the border give me a
[ __ ] break they were locking them all
in cages
and Greg Abbott is now in charge
Greg Abbott
is the governor the executor the
Executive Branch the head of a [ __ ]
border state the biggest border state
where they claim they have a biggest
[ __ ] problem maybe the problem isn't
the [ __ ] border or the people coming
across it Craig Abbott maybe the [ __ ]
problem is people like you're bigoted
dumbass you're Un-American human
trafficking criminal dumbass you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the problem don't you see folks
the person that is in charge of Texas is
causing the problem you want to change
it do you want to change the problem you
want to fix the Border crisis Greg
Abbott go vote for Ben O'Rourke
go back go vote for someone who will
[ __ ] do something about immigration
who will [ __ ] put their goddamn shoes
on in the [ __ ] morning and do their
goddamn job
not spend our Goddamn money and the tax
payers money for a political stunt to
make you feel good
you [ __ ] racist piece of [ __ ]
it's time for Texas
to get on their [ __ ] feet
and get to the [ __ ] polls and engage
in that democracy and get rid of this
piece of [ __ ] the person who is causing
the problem in Texas that's what other
[ __ ] conclusion can you draw
he's the one in charge of the Border
Republicans can fix everything remember
they're so good at fixing everything
well Greg Abbott is causing the problem
obviously he can't get his border under
control
what the [ __ ] wrong with him just I
mean God damn how long has he been the
[ __ ] Governor he should have fixed it
how long was Trump the president he
should have [ __ ] fixed it he didn't
[ __ ] fix it they made it worse
because they don't want people coming
here they don't want brown people here
they want this to be a Christian white
Nation that's what they want
in our country our economy our great
nation relies on migrants
relies on immigration expanding our
economy growing our diversity
our passion for the American dream of
coming here
and making something of yourself so your
kids and your grandkids
can make something of themselves
who'da thought that these [ __ ] these
[ __ ] fascists would lose sight of
what democracy really can do huh who
would have thought
who would have thought
well Greg Abbott looks like you need to
get fired because you're the problem
down there at the border I mean you're
in charge of the border of Texas aren't
you
hmm I don't know I'm just saying
[ __ ] them fire him higher higher Beto
see if he can do a better job it's time
for some change down there at the border
and [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] okay
oh here is uh here's a great um here's a
great uh video
it shows you uh it shows you how Fox uh
actually views this and then how the
people at Martha's Vineyard view this
watch this
now those have a home Oprah Beyonce even
James Taylor
who's going to be seeing fire rain and
migrants uh not to mention Rosie
O'Donnell I mean everybody basically
do you think they're going to be
embracing their new neighbors you know
these are all Sanctuary
we sent we sent them some brand people
oh they're definitely gonna turn them
away
they're definitely gonna treat him like
trash and then we're gonna show those
libtards let's watch our cities until
they're in their Sanctuary right there
was no welcome coming party so the group
wandered some three and a half miles to
Martha's Vineyard Community Services in
Edgartown immigrants who were told that
they would be greeted here with a place
to stay and with jobs we have volunteers
from the fire department police
department the hospital has sent people
over the high school sent people who
spoke Spanish to help translate
it's literally all hands on deck of the
community now this is where oh well
looky there looking there the community
bands together to help these people you
would think I you would think that um
Ron DeSantis could have found a way to
spend 12 million bucks
to help these people hell a lot more
than sending them somewhere for these
people to go all hands on deck to help
these people these refugees these future
Americans these Future Leaders of
America that's who they're going to be
doubt me
you're gonna hear stories 20 30 years
from now about these people who have
made their lives who have made their
livings after they were shipped on a
plane to Martha's Vineyard
it's gonna be a story about it on the
news somewhere and you're gonna see it
[Music]
um
it's just it's despicable and it's
Un-American and frankly it's not what
Jesus would do so if you claim to be
Christian out there and you're talking
about how you want to take away rights
from women you want to kill women
because you want them to force
birth on them and you want it you want
to get rid of refugees and you want to
send refugees to Martha's Vineyard so
they they go there and they can die
there oh
you're not American and you can go get
[ __ ] um here is here's uh speaking of
Nazis and then American maybe we'll get
back to the Nazi talk here's uh here's
Stephen Miller with his take his hot
take on Martha's Vineyard
anti-inforcement anti-constitution
policy so my message this is really
[ __ ] stupid by the way this is really
[ __ ] stupid the only reason why these
people the reason why these people uh
the well the problem that they have
getting back to their [ __ ] their
Asylum hearings
is because they were processed Joe
Biden's DHS did process these people to
give their Asylum
it's Christ
in every instance that you can take the
illegal immigrants in your state where
the law allows you to and put them into
the neighborhood of Rich Democrats that
are financing Joe Biden put them into
Silicon Valley where Mark Zuckerberg
lives
into Hyannis Port now listen to what
this [ __ ] Nazi says he wants you to
ship them all around the country which
you know I I'm actually not opposed to I
actually think we should send these
people all over the country
yeah let's let's get this economy
roaring let's get it going these people
want to come here they want to work
they're eager to be part of our country
what are you [ __ ] nuts they want to
be part of our economy that's why they
[ __ ] come here for safety
capitalism free market Liberty that's
why they came here now but listen to
what this [ __ ] scumbag says about
tent cities and camps
put them into Nantucket put them into
every Rich exclusive Democrat enclave
and by the way I can think of no better
place than Martha's Vineyard because if
you actually believe the nonsense that
these are Asylum Seekers and these are
not these are illegal immigrants coming
here for jobs and benefits yeah they're
coming here for jobs dummy they're
coming here for jobs what are you
talking about so you're saying lazy
[ __ ] lazy no good brown people
are coming here for jobs and that's a
bad thing you are such
a piece of [ __ ]
Martha's Vineyard is the place we should
set up tents we should set up shelters
and they should be there while they're
waiting for their Heroes
well it's exactly on
shelters camps he wants to shout out set
up shelters and camps and who would have
thought that a Nazi would want to set up
camps
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
oh
Republican Jesus oh republican Jesus it
is something else and that Republican
Jesus there's a video going around again
of Republican Jesus
this is hilarious I want to show this in
its full entirety let's watch truly I
say unto you
whoever welcomes one of these little
ones in my name
might be letting in a murderer or a drug
let's get her to a Detention Center
you know so we can
figure out what's going on
[Music]
I was hungry and you gave me something
to eat I was thirsty and you gave me
something to drink and behold now I'm
all lazy and entitled you shouldn't have
done that do unto others as you suspect
they might want to do unto you what is a
man profited if he gained the whole
world but lose his soul
a lot he has profited a lot one soul for
the whole world that is an amazing deal
why do you look at the speck of dust in
your brother's eye but ignore the plank
in your own
because of her emails yes if a man
strikes you on the right cheek turn to
him and shoot him
that is the law if you want to be
perfect go
sell all the possessions that you have
and give the money to a solid mutual
fund by this they will know that you are
my disciples
that you say Merry Christmas
christ Christmas that's my name in there
and I put it in there because I wanted
it in there so we could all celebrate
Big Boy Jesus birthday time
okay
okay
surely you can heal me my child of
course I could
but who would pay for it
I don't understand I don't have any
money yes it is a sad story
but it does not make me responsible
it is super dupe
dupe for a rich man to end
gold house just to be sure love your
neighbor as yourself
unless you are better than your neighbor
then tell them
that they're weird
and you do not want to bake them a cake
you have heard it said Thou shalt not
commit adultery but I say to you any man
who looks upon a woman with lust in his
heart should go ahead and do what he's
got to do Lord your followers grow
hungry and we have only this fish and
bread oh sweet
[Music]
and Republican Jesus any agree Jesus
what would Republican Jesus do really
oh my God okay let's do this let's take
a break we're gonna come back with more
shitless Roundup right after these
messages don't go around don't go
anywhere do not go anywhere stick right
there we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babble
Mega Edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon I was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that I'm
struggling with I chose Babel mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
are you guys watching the show on Tony
Michaels dot live if you are and you
want to chat down at the bottom of the
video there's a little twitch
logo there you just click on Twitch and
that'll take you over to Twitch where
you can join the live chat also if
you're watching on Tony Michaels live
Tony Michaels dot live if you're on a
desktop computer you can actually do the
chat from your web browser
from your web browser
[Laughter]
everyone's saying that that the mods are
saying they we need to have a uh a
meeting about the the muting my mic in
appropriate ways so here's the problem
is I don't get um I don't have a
on on the software that we have that we
stream out I don't actually get a volume
control and we're trying to work that
out I want to get a something that we
run the volume through differently so
that way I have a little more control
over it because I don't have as much
control the way we do the show right now
that's just the way it goes but uh Robin
here are a great moderator and MJ are
talking that we need to have a private
meeting
uh my uh my my mic everyone give the
moderators uh great love in the Chant we
haven't been on YouTube so I know
they've been missing their YouTube
moderating but
we sure have uh been doing some
moderating over on Twitch and again if
you're on Tony Michaels dot live again
don't forget you can go watch now live
every single weekday at Tony Michaels
dot Live support Independent Media there
you guys can give a one-time tip or a
monthly tip there at tonymichaels dot
live to help support Independent Media
help support our Channel help to support
our show we are we we're really
apologizing that
YouTube
um gave us a seven day ban that's really
what happened is we were banned for
seven days for posting
so here's what happens when you when you
have a YouTube channel if you have a if
you have a strike or a warning then you
get a strike and that strike what
happens is they they suspend you for
temporarily now if if I have another
strike in the next 90 days then they'll
suspend us for two weeks
that's why I open that's why we started
this website tonymichaels.live so they
can't silence us YouTube or anyone for
that matter because now we have a
website where we will stream live every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube when we get back from our
suspension
twitch and Twitter and also from the
Facebook page don't forget we we
simulcast you might as touch Facebook
page but also follow me on Facebook
you can find all those Links at Tony
Michaels dot live just click the little
sandwich icon at the top or there's the
logos Facebook
YouTube Tick Tock twitch Twitter
Instagram you can go follow us on all
the platforms
so please go follow us on all the
platforms stay in touch with us we're
probably gonna open a Discord soon too
um I think Gabe actually opened a
channel this morning so we'll be we'll
be doing that I don't know if you guys
know what Discord is I'm still learning
what Discord is and but apparently it's
a place where we can all gather up and
talk to each other like-minded
pro-democracy people can have
discussions with like-minded
pro-democracy people
where we can you know do some planning
some organizing engage in our democracy
there and I think we can actually even
stream the show there as well so be
watching as we announce our Discord and
where the Discord will be and what
Discord is and I don't mean to make you
download all kinds of apps with twitch
and Discord
but we're going to get this figured out
we're going to figure out how to make
sure that you guys get your your dose
your daily dose
of cathartic pro-democracy speech every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central
for two full hours two full hours so go
to Tony Michaels dot Live support
independent independent medium Pro
democracy speech there tell it tell me
what you think about the website
and I'll comment on Twitter go to
Facebook comment there you can comment
on Instagram comment on Tick Tock I try
to look at all those things and make
sure do me a huge favor and let's Show
YouTube what we're worth make sure to go
over the YouTube channel if you haven't
subscribed over there already to the
Tony Michaels podcast because we're only
a few days left on this suspension
and we will be back on YouTube soon and
don't forget to download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify Google
your favorite directory don't forget to
go there
okay let's get back to the shitless
Roundup here I think um I think we had
enough of that actually you know what
let's do one more pitch here the dark
Brandon shirts Everyone likes the dark
Brandon shirts who doesn't want a dark
Brandon shirt
we got dark Brandon merchandise over at
store.thetonymichaels.com if you go to
Tony Michaels dot live you'll see the
dark Brandon
uh link there you just click the little
picture of the T-shirt it'll take you to
where you can go purchase your dark
Brandon merch there's coffee mugs
there's there's hoodies there's stickers
and also you can get your uh Rhonda
santis can go [ __ ] himself merch over
there at store.the tonymichaels.com
while you're there while you're there
you can pick up some of that that was a
hot
a hot design I made that design you know
you get pissed off at Rhonda Santos what
do you do you make art and I made this
little Meme and I was like you know what
that'd go perfect
perfect on a t-shirt so we put it on a
t-shirt [ __ ] it put it on a t-shirt now
let's see here and it it do oh I want to
um I want to show you the uh
uh the video of the five percent who
want to commit Vine this is this is
actually kind of a hilarious video
it's kind of hilarious actually
um
I know I know you don't think so but it
is kind of funny this is face Face the
Nation where they're talking about them
uh
the the five percent of Americans who
want to commit violence to reinstate
Trump as president King let's listen uh
when we spoke back in January about the
research you've done at that point you
issued a warning that stuck with us
because you talked about the threat of
political violence around the midterm
elections we are 50 days away
what are you worried about now
Margaret we have not just a political
threat to our democracy we have a
violent threat to our democracy it's
important to remember that January 6
wasn't just trespassing and going into a
federal building thousands of
individuals use violence to stop the
peaceful transfer of Presidential Power
what we have been tracking at our Center
at the University of Chicago the Chicago
project on security and threats for a
year and a half is the violent portion
of that insurrectionist movement today
there are millions of individuals who
don't just think the election was stolen
in 2020 they support violence to restore
Donald Trump to the White House in fact
just over the weekend that is just a few
days ago we conducted our most recent
nationally representative survey to
okay here's the numbers
that they're saying is in this survey
okay
so this is the question is is force
Justified to restore Trump to the White
House
and this would this would this would
assume violence Force meaning violence
agape
now on the disagree side you have 83
percent
which if you do the numbers that's 214
million Americans
okay now this is just a survey in this
poll that 83 and Bill and man people
like
what's 12 percent
the people who agreed that forces
Justified was only five percent now if
you look at these numbers this is what
I've been telling you for a long long
time
that there's about 15 16 of this country
that have lost their [ __ ] minds
they've lost their minds they're
delusional they've been mind [ __ ] they
just don't understand
now this isn't voters
this isn't voters this is this is just
people who want to
use Force to overthrow the government to
make Donald Trump president King like
the guy in the clown costume that showed
up in a Dairy Queen in in Pennsylvania
I'm not [ __ ] you that's real
a guy in a clown costume or a clown wig
went into a Dairy Queen
to Crown Donald Trump president King
he's one of the fine percent all right
the Ted is brain melted his brainwashed
his mind [ __ ] like a fake Gabe over
there on Facebook you know he's mind
[ __ ] he's getting he's got the Ben
Shapiro and the the [ __ ] Fox News a
long time probably Newsmax too
you know just just chipping away at
what's left of them brain cells you know
making him a full-on Maga fascist
but here we have here we have the
numbers here and it's not surprising
these are numbers that I've been talking
about I've been saying these numbers for
a long time
but only five percent only five percent
so if you do the math
if you got 10 people
10 people in a room
likely only a half of those people
is gonna is gonna use Force
to restore Trump
now let's make it more accurate
let's say let's say there's a hundred
people in a room
and a hundred people living in our
democracy
benefiting from our democracy benefiting
from the Liberty the rights the freedoms
that our democracy affords you
you think those 95 people are gonna let
the five stupid bastards that want to
top on our democracy you think that's
what they're gonna do
okay folks
these nincompoop Nazis are a hard hard
minority
in this country hard minority
because I believe the actual nincompoop
Nazis that went and gave the Nazi salute
with the one finger the people who are
always in the chats the [ __ ] trolls
out there
who are always who are always talking
[ __ ] saying Hunter Biden's laptop her
emails and all this nonsense
it's only five percent of them the
problem is the fine percent is really
loud [ __ ] really loud
[ __ ] imagine imagine if we just
got half
of the 83 being as loud as the five
percent we could drown them son of a
[ __ ] out we could drown them out I
think that's actually what's happening I
think that's what's happening is as the
country is seeing what the five percent
who they truly are
for the fascist bigots who want to take
your freedom and your Liberty away from
you by making sure that women don't have
the right to their bodily autonomy to
make sure that they go even further and
ban all abortion for no exceptions
whatsoever
they want they wanna they wanna treat
brown people like their pieces of meats
and political props spend millions of
dollars
on PR stunts when that millions of
dollars could go to actually helping
thousands of migrants coming to our
country and let's let's spend millions
of dollars around DeSantis I will
partner with your dumb fashion SAS
to coordinate to use the money to get
those migrants throughout the country
legally and in an orderly fashion so
they can become integral parts of our
economy integral parts of our country
become citizens in this country you
goddamn right that's what I want
that's what I want
there's only five percent of people out
there that are yelling and screaming
about this believe this hatred and
there's only 12 percent of them that are
willing to capitulate to the five right
that's what this thing tells me if this
if these numbers are true
there's only a handful of bigots in this
country
but there's about double or triple that
that are willing to capitulate to those
real [ __ ] bigots
and the rest of us are pro-democracy we
want our lifestyles we don't care who
who someone else loves what someone else
wants to identify it as
what the hell genitalia they have in
their pants are obsessed with that too
we're not
we don't care if you want to
if you want to come here and live in
Texas or go to Martha's Vineyard if you
want to seek a job if you want to get a
a good paying job if you want to get an
education we just don't want you to go
broke because of a medical bill
we want you to practice a religion that
you want to practice or no no religion
at all we want you to have that Liberty
we want you to have the liberty of not
having to
worry from paycheck to paycheck you want
to make a decent wage we're all for that
Liberty here in this country
we're we actually want you to come here
contribute to our economy contribute to
our country
contribute to our side as society and
you know what as a matter of fact we
want your children to get educated and
your grandchildren to get educated so
they can become integral parts of our
economy integral parts of our country be
great American citizens
the American citizens that we look for
not just five percent of people who are
autocrats who are who are delusional
sheep
who are who are nincompoop Nazis
fascists that want this [ __ ] idiot
this buffoon this bozo being our
dictator
democracy is what is what will Deliver
Us
these five percent crawling back
underneath their rocks
it's what will make us
will make us strong again
make America strong
again
strong against the forces of the fascist
against Maga Republicans people who want
to tear down our democracy who want to
destroy our democracy to make a white
Christian fascist state
because that's what they want
that's what they want why do you think
they they adhere to Fascism it's the
easiest way to that point
it always has been
they're the American Taliban
and they're dead set on destroying our
democracy
but folks it's only five percent of them
if this is real which I actually think
five percent is is being [ __ ]
generous
five percent is being generous that is
the fraud that this [ __ ] Cheeto dust
mobster Grandpa Poopypants this orange
Mussolini Jesus
has wrought on our country is that half
the country supports him get the [ __ ]
out of here with that nonsense
if there's a poll out there that you can
go to to say that he ain't got the
support he says he has this is it
everyone acts like this is a scary poll
I actually think this is good [ __ ]
news folks
there's only five percent which again I
think is being generous there's only
five percent of the country that's
willing to go to battle for this idiot
and you look at the number you're like
13 million
where are they gonna go
where the [ __ ] are they gonna go
I'll tell you what they're gonna do
they're not they're not gonna they're
not going to go in the streets and riot
they're not going to use violence to
take over our governments
if he's indicted where are they going to
go if he's indicted to take over our
government
where are they gonna go in the midterms
when when the Blue Wave comes they're
going to go to every single County
Office
every single election office with
violence to take over you think that's
gonna work
that's not what they're that's not what
they're planning folks they're trying to
get you scared of violence so you don't
do the things that democracies do which
is folk these [ __ ] autocrats these
[ __ ] fascists these goddamn
nincompoop Nazis out
they're trying to scare you the 83
percent that's what they're trying to do
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em engage
in your democracy lean into that [ __ ]
use your ballot as a hammer to smash
fascism
and it's going to take more than just
this election but by God this is it this
is the one that we need to lean into
right now we are right there row row row
your vote November get out there talk to
people it doesn't matter what issue
you're talking about you make them the
enemy
because they're coming for your
democracy they're coming for it
they're coming for your [ __ ] Liberty
they're given Nazi signs Nazi salutes at
Nazi rallies
for crying out loud
and there's a bunch of them capitulating
so you don't capitulate don't capitulate
to these fascists
and take this seriously
check your registration
ask your family your friends your
colleagues
your fellow parishioners at the church
to check their registration go get
people registered to vote oh my God
women are lining up in droves to
register
because of how they want to take their
[ __ ] rights away from them their
lives they want to take their lives
these forced birthers want to take
women's lives away from them
with no no exceptions not even the
woman's life
we see who they are
you see who they are go convey the
message
go engage not doors for your favorite
candidate if you got a little extra
change in your couch give it to them
five dollars ten dollars twenty dollars
it will make a difference
it costs money to get these the
advertising out it costs money to get
people to go knock doors they gotta
gotta make sure they have water we gotta
treat them like human beings gotta feed
them some sandwiches give them some
energy
to get them to all these doors we have
to let these people know
we're not going to let the fine percent
tell us what the [ __ ] to do are we that
ain't the kind of democracy we live in
is to let 13 million people tell the
rest of us
250 million people what the [ __ ] we're
gonna do
are you [ __ ] me
that's not the Democracy I live in
that's not the Democracy I'm gonna live
in and I'm gonna push and push and push
every single weekday
every single one of them noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific right here
at this microphone
you better go to tonymichaels.live we
are on a YouTube band so we're not on
YouTube this week but we will get over
the troll Farms targeting our YouTube
and we will finally get back on YouTube
but [ __ ] go to tonymichaels.live you can
watch us there every single weekday for
two full hours you can also watch us on
Twitch Twitter
the books of face all of you on Facebook
whether you're on the Midas touch page
or my page follow us everywhere go to
tonymichaels.live support Independent
Media
I really appreciate you guys hanging
with us this week even though we have
the YouTube band I'm not able to post
anything over there I can't even post a
message that we're banned isn't that
ridiculous I would say they would at
least give me the opportunity to post
one message to say hey we have a a
posting band for seven days nope nope
won't even let me do that
so again
go bookmark Tony Michaels dot Live join
us every single day Monday through
Friday go to the new website tell us
what you think about the new website too
go follow us over on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and tell us what you think
of the new website what would you change
what would you do different
also download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directories make sure to leave us a
great review while you're there
subscribing and don't forget to go to
YouTube go to YouTube and show your
support there show them what we're made
of subscribe to the YouTube channel
because we're going to be back in a few
days on YouTube
loud and proud and also go follow us on
Twitch you don't want to miss us over
there as well follow us on all the
platforms Facebook twitch Twitter
YouTube
because we're gonna be bringing it to
you every single weekday Monday through
Friday just like we did today just like
we do every weekday and tomorrow
tomorrow we have Gabe Sanchez back our
co-host and executive producer
extraordinaire Gabe Sanchez is going to
be joining us tomorrow
don't forget to go visit uh
store.ttonymichaels.com for these new
Rhonda santis can go [ __ ] himself
designs give us some support over there
as well as giving us some support
there on Tony Michaels dot live you can
donate give a one-time tip or you can do
a monthly tip all your all your
your support is appreciated whether you
give support through money to keep us
going
rather you buy merch
rather you just come and listen and
spread the message
retweet share it
send it to someone in an email
I appreciate all of you and all the kind
words that you sent as our YouTube band
happened on Friday
um and and how you guys really were
trying to find where to watch this thing
it may it meant a lot to me and I know
you guys rely on this show over your
cathartic outrage the Strategic outrage
to engage in your democracy because
pro-democracy speech is important
and I know I use a lot of the f word and
a lot of profanity but I try to deliver
you try to deliver you the news
in a way that makes sense
that isn't all garbly [ __ ] that isn't
bogged down by the Queen's funeral who
gives a rat's ass we got a lot better
[ __ ] to do to save in this country than
to worry about that some Monarch being
buried in the ground
I had respect the first couple days but
it's past that time we gotta save our
[ __ ] democracy
ours
is in big trouble
and we must save it so come every single
weekday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific Tony Michaels dot live
bookmarket
we'll see you same time same place
tomorrow Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon